I don't care if they have my information. All
I do is watch cat videos all day. Saying you
have nothing to hide is not true, nor
is it realistic. When you sign up for a
social media app, you agree to the privacy
policy. You read that, right? Yeah. Well,
I actually did for a really popular app and yes,
it was long and boring, but there's something
you should know when you post a video to your
friends. The platform calls this "user content",
and on the user content they can obtain
information such as location data from your
SIM card or IP address. Then it could analyze
the video using its algorithms to identify
faces or other objects. It may even obtain device
information like battery level, apps and file names,
and even keystroke patterns. So if you're going to
take away anything from this video, know that when
you go online and use social media apps, there's
really no such thing as private, only less public.